yeah i want to pull up this story um
it's actually a series of tweets the
story is actually an uh an opinion piece
from jack bosovic from newsweek this
year's olympics will double as xi
jinping's coronation this was a
fantastic probably the best piece that's
ever been written in newsweek i think i
do like how you you referenced your own
article with wow you saw that
it was pretty good it was an okay piece
so i i tweeted out the yeah the excerpts
from the article but i took my name i
cut it so that you couldn't see my name
and i just wrote wow
so check us out check us out uh this is
a guy i believe he's from the southern
poverty law center right yes he said
very highly credible highly friendly
newsweek i wanna hear what he has to say
newsweek just published an op-ed by
neo-nazi collaborator and stop the steel
liar jack posobik this guy is beneath
oan and not o-a-n-n now just extremely
embarrassing maddie hassan then says
congrats to newsweek opinion editors
josh hammer and bungar sargon
for their ongoing struggle to mainstream
and normalize the conspiracists far
right in this country now what i just
want to mention we were talking about
earlier is how they keep trying to do
this this smear of calling someone a
nazi far right or whatever and i just
like here we are sitting with jack
posobik who's a nice guy who talks about
politics and not once have i heard him
espouse anything in any way supportive
of any of these groups i actually talked
about and it's funny to hear media
assange say that because mediasan was a
presenter for al jazeera for many many
years and has spoken out again he made
his bones in in reporting and later at
huffington post speaking out against
islamophobia well many if you had
actually taken the time to read the
words that i wrote in newsweek there's
actually a whole section in there about
the concentration camps of uyghur
muslims in xinjiang
that
may be something where we could actually
agree on so there's two points here
there was around i wanted to bring this
up i mean for one you're here so we can
talk about it hi calling you
these names like a neo nazi collaborator
it's just i i don't believe any regular
person any any you know you you you go
knock on a random door and you show it
to them they're gonna go oh shut up like
i just don't believe these people
anymore like you you go to a local house
of a guy who's not in politics and he's
going to raid that and be like i don't
believe it you look at maddie hassan
who's now pushing the same narrative but
like you said he didn't even read what
you wrote it's the same thing with the
joe rogan story everyone i love the meme
going around where it's like joe rogan
spreading misinformation
oh really what did he say
nobody knows
see that's how dangerous it is it's the
silence dissident voices mouse culture
revolution you cannot even talk to your
family about anything because what if
your family member
report to the local red cards then they
could go to struggle sessions so i had a
self-censor when i started to ask
questions i only asked myself inside of
my own head i could not say well wait
tim do me a favor you're on mediason's
page right there do you see over to the
right where it has mediason's bio right
now does it say where mediason currently
works yeah it works for nbc so he works
for nbc and he has a
a show also on nbc's peacock which is
their streaming service now
i did a little digging on this um really
really deep digging it took me you know
seconds of time to search this up nbc
signed an 8 billion dollar contract
with the international olympic committee
to be their exclusive host for the
olympics all the way through 2032 and
then the exclusive streaming service of
the olympics is and it's so strange
peacock tv the exact same place from
eddie hassan has his streaming service
so it's so strange to me that
such a coincidence
they used to actually you know have
front groups for this sort of thing now
they're just doing it in the open like
try harder guys come on i just saw this
story and like i mentioned the the the
trying to smear you then not even
reading the article the joe rogan
spreads lies but we don't actually
listen to a show anyway and i'm just
like i don't think they're
i think i think they've lost i think
they've outright lost
the establishment
yeah so so that's the other thing i want
to bring up michael malus responded to
mehdi hassan saying impotence signaling
is much funnier than virtue signaling
they've lost monopoly control over the
mic and don't know what to do except
sneer virtue signal of course being like
look at me so virtuous i condemn that
too but now they're just going like we
can't do anything about this so we're
losers people are listening to joe rogan
and they're not and
jack besovic is getting written up in
newsweek what do we do well and and and
just to to mike i you know i appreciate
it so why would they call me them
sitting next to jack
no exactly you're a collaborator you're
now a collaborator
we talked about the other day there's
nothing we're all posting collaborators
no no look we we talked about yesterday
there's a tweet that's going viral where
a guy says in germany we have a saying
if there's 11 if there's 11 people if
there's a neo-nazi singer table and 10
people at the table talking to him you
have 11 nazis and that is a psychotic
world view but it proves to the left
politics can only flow in one direction
if you take an antifa guy sit him at a
table and you take jack pasoba and
simmet the same table and they're
talking the left will look at it and say
two far right individuals even though
the one guy's clearly got an antifa flag
and wearing a mask and everything they
don't care we have a picture of
you know that you follow guys so that's
what they want to do they want to shut
down any kind of discussions
conversations by name well lily yeah let
me ask you a question when chairman mao
launched the uh
uh
his anti-rightist campaign what was
every person so who spoke out if you
spoke out against the great leap forward
and you said hey there's millions of
people who are dying of famine in the
countryside what were you labeled
well
you will lose your job you will get
locked up that's why the people don't
understand when you say ccp dictatorship
means
all the leaders in china are not elected
by people they are appointed by the
upper nine communist party officials so
they actually want to cover it up so
when people die of starvation during the
great leap forward in the 50s x 50
meaning people died but they don't want
to report that to the central government
because they can local government
officials can lose their jobs they're
trying to cover up same thing with kobe
same thing with the stars it's same
thing with flooding so it's very
dangerous here's one thing on team i
want to tell you because of your good
work and our discussion somebody texts
me they just donate it and they live in
new hampshire oh cool
you're getting messages from people
saying they're donating to your oh great
thank you very much you got really angry
about the gun rights thing and mentioned
having the ar 15 everybody was cheering
very very happy so you would be right so
they would so the officially and they
would and they would conduct the
struggle sessions and it would be around
your neck you would be labeled a right
wing extremist for saying there were
people dying and can of famine and
committing even in some cases
cannibalism in the countryside just so
they could survive remember this this
the raider guard like a raid guard do
you have struck sessions did you say
this 201 yeah yeah 2020. i've seen
college students in america march down
the street doing the red salute yep yes
well so lily speaking of college
students and these types of people one
question i want to ask you lily is prior
to the maoist revolution did you know
people who were leftists or communists
or was it just a very well organized
small minority that ended up
infiltrating and taking over
were the people calling for this or how
did this happen
well of course i had no idea i was born
like a into the mouse culture i was two
years old to 12 years old i was totally
indoctrinated i had no idea we were just
told that the taiwan people are starving
to that and lots of people are living in
hell we need to go labor them and we
need to be grateful for the party for my
mom i would just because i still had a
little bit brain right i said but we're
starving now it's like how could be
worse off they were right i mean to us
but it doesn't matter you self-censor
you don't ask questions i never
challenged anything in my life until i
was 12 years old when mao died it's like
oh my god died because the weight
chanted every day long never to my mom
10 000 years double ten thousand years
until he died it was like oh you know
who lied to me that's what i was
wondering i was whispering to myself and
i decided to go to college study law so
i can change china maybe search for
truth but by the time i went to law
school and then they told me no no no no
it's not for justice no is a tool used
by the party to govern its masses soviet
union model
i got lost again really i had lots of
very depressive totally so lost moments
in my life until i came to this country
you were telling us last time you hear
that you had to like lie to try and get
out of the country and pretend that you
would you know you lied and claimed you
would come back yeah everything has to
be pc because you need the permission of
the party to quit your job otherwise you
pay money back you'll need permission to
go get a passport so i
that's why i call myself a straight red
because i had to survive if i want to
come to united states for my freedom i
had to say whatever is pc oh i'm gonna
get a college master degree here in the
us to serve my country better on my own
time on my own time i will come back to
serve my country okay sign agreement the
agreement is i must promise to go back
to china after my master's degree okay
or two consequences will kick you out of
the party
because
you know i was forced to join party in
order to teach in law school as a
faculty member you must have the party
membership otherwise they don't trust
you or your loyalty you got to be loyal
to the party so i don't care about that
okay you can't kick me out i was on
probation status anyway first year i
hate it because i just could not believe
anymore then next one is very hard they
kick you
a personnel file to your hometown which
is chandusuchwan because if you live
work in shanghai you must have your
personal file to go with your job but if
you don't go back on time they kick your
file back to chengdu so that means i i
there's no hope i can go back to
shanghai and live there as legal
resident have a benefit because that
ties to your benefits
so i guess chairman square that the
political asylum status kind of you know
gave to every chinese student so i was
okay later to go back to china but but i
had to cancel my trip 2019 because i was
threatened how dare you speak bad about
your motherland in the united states two
students
so i said i'm teaching the truth no
you're a traitor
so i was threatened when was the last
time you were home
2015. i missed my home wow my family my
extended relative one brother three
uncles one aunt and cousins
i met some people who traveled through
north korea and they told me that
if there is like a small town or village
and they have a cow and the cow dies
they can't touch it they have to call
the local military officer who's you
know appointed to come and take the cow
to be distributed evenly among the
country for everybody
if you take it to eat because you're
starving they they put you in the work
camps or they outright kill you and
execute your family
so it's just
you know you don't know every day every
minute you could be breaking the law
that's how bad look when you talk about
oppressive reaching
it it's just people have no rights you
are treated like some animals without
human dignity everything you say
everything you do you are criminal i
don't hate to see americans becoming
like that way there's so many laws you
don't know which day you will be
breaking the laws you mean like if
somebody was holding the door open for
you at the u.s capitol and you walked
inside unbeknownst because you thought
that you were just at a protest and now
suddenly you're put in a gulag the
police opened the door for the police
not just somebody
i don't agree with it but i respect your
right to protest waving you in
and now those people are yep
yeah it's ridiculous yeah that's where
we're at
well maybe trump will get reelected and
pardon a bunch of people or something
but i don't think they're getting that
long of presence trump
should really
do something right now for the people
that are behind bars right and if he
could do something set up a legal fund
set up a way just just he can't tweet
anymore but he could post it through his
um you know through his press release do
something for the people now show people
that you're still in the fight if you
want people to know that you're serious
do something for the people because
guess what they don't have the ability
they don't have the luxury of waiting
until 2025. they're behind bars right
now
what can they have every citizen
supposed to have their speed in trial
you cannot hold people this longer uh
supposedly no political prisoners in a
free country it's like why are the
people still locked up without the
trials
you know we we need to do something and
question it to say hey we need to
advocate you know they should have a
speedy trial and you should have jewelry
and then you should you should have all
it means like it's become so political
now so you can get bail out if you're
violent criminals and burn stuff and
looting property somebody will raise 23
million dollars for you to get out you
come out you commit another crime you
kill more people but those people
january 6.
you know they're still in the jail lily
and i think the exact reason for that is
because unfortunately uh most americans
don't value the principles upon which
this nation was founded as much as you
do as a citizen and i think the ones who
do value it are too complacent to
actually do anything about it
so they bought into the media rhetoric
and uh have you i think i think many of
them the thing is i think many people
haven't bought into the media rhetoric
but it happened a while ago they're not
thinking about it it wasn't me it wasn't
my family it wasn't anyone i care about
so i'm just going to forget it just like
just like the people saying nazi germany
by the time they came for me there's
nobody left to defend me
that's how you lose a country so fast
solzhenitsyn wrote about that he said a
lot of the people who when they were
brought away by the guards um they would
be told they would say oh well they were
asked to come they said well i'll just
go down because this is a big mistake
and i know i didn't yeah i'll go
downtown yeah i'll go downstairs explain
things and they never came home but the
you know we were talking about uh
fundraising a second ago and i don't
know if you guys have seen the story
that andrew kerr uh leads to the
washington examiner now uh has been
reporting about blm and the donations of
blm and the fact that they walked out of
2020 with 60 million dollars in the bank
and we remember that in the wake of the
george floyd video going viral there
were companies just throwing literally
throwing money at blm but andrew curr is
actually doing the work now and i think
he even went to their registered address
in los angeles and is trying to figure
out hey so who's in charge of the money
right who's in charge of like who are
the actual fiduciary uh stakeholders
here who is responsible for the 60
million dollars he can't because we saw
people uh patrice colors and others have
resigned from blm so who's actually in
charge of the money he can't find anyone
who's in charge of this didn't he say
the address wasn't even legit like he
went there there's nothing there right
and the guy said they've never been here
and then they said well hold on but we
we appointed two people who to serve as
the new you know the new runners the new
chairman of blm but then those he went
and interviewed those people and they
said oh yeah they appointed us but we
never accepted wow so we never accepted
the appointment so that's fraud that's
60 million dollars of fraud right there
and so if that's all true and he's by
the way he's saying that i think um
uh i think the state ag is actually
opening up an investigation into this
because that that's straight up
non-profit fraud if that's what's going
on thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time